A few weeks ago you said if we were going to do the Joe Tippen's protocol, we should run a complete metabolic panel
Right, so the reason why I said that is it can often lead to
Because Joe Tippen's protocol is using fendbendisol, so you're using fendbendisol
Which is the dog dewormer
Orally and it can like any medication affect your liver, so we want to look at
Your alcohol phosphates your AST and ALT most specifically. I've been at a curcumin forever
I just started the A-POP E which is the vitamin E
Bermurate and CBD oil. That's part of this is all part of Joe Tippen's protocol
The creatinine and the E-G-F-R out of range slightly any concerns
So her bug is 23 creatinine is 1.6
Estimated glomerular filtration rate, which is the E-G-F-R is 53
So the creatinine and the estimated glomerular filtration rate are kidney
Function tests
Based upon your labs, your kidneys are strained
Is it because of the fendbendisol, adding that?
Again, you'd want to look at history
so
If you have a history of your creatinine and your E-G-F-R going up and down
And being out of range at different times, then I would say stay on the protocol
If boy, it's never been underage. I've looked at my history and it's never been underage
Then I would say that I would say you might want to pulse the fendbendisol
Which means maybe go off of it for two weeks and then back on again
So you're maybe two weeks on two weeks off so you're pulsing it
Again, I mentioned that fendbendisol being a medication can affect your liver
can elevate your AST, ALT, and alkaline phosphatase, most commonly
But it can affect your kidneys as well. So these are kidney function tests that are out of range
Could it be the fendbendisol? It certainly could
That's the only thing you're really changed
Certainly not the supplements, but it could be the fendbendisol
So maybe pulse that
But again, I'd look at your history
So you look at your blood tests over time, that's what you're looking for, the clues
And if you have a history of these numbers going out of range and back in range
And they were even out of range
You know, at the last test that you'd say there really isn't any difference between the two tests
If they were within range, at your last blood test, your last complete metabolic panel
And now they're out of range that I would consider pulsing it